Guten Tag, ich bin Yahya Afche und ich bin der Dienstabender Ars auf dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschäft übernommen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Ja, so ars möte ich ein paar Ihren persönlichen Daten fragen.
Ja, okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Gerne. Ich heiße Manfred Müller.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vornahme burscht haben?
Ja, also Manfred wie M-A-N-L-R-E-D.
Ja, okay.
Und wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 55 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie?
Ich bin 15. September 1967.
55, ja.
57, ja.
67, ja, 67.
Ja, 67.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 86 kg schwer.
61 kg schwer.
Okay.
Was für Sie so uns?
Was wird mich zujähnen?
Also ich habe seit ein paar Tagen so Bauchschmerzen.
Und vor zwei Tagen hatte ich auch mal Fieber gehabt.
Wo genau, deswegen?
Also im Bauchbereich, um die Nabel herunter.
Ja, und Nabel.
Und wann genau haben die Schmerzen begonnen?
Also ich kann nicht genau sagen, aber das sind vielleicht so 3-5 Tage her.
3-5 Tage.
Und sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich abgetragen?
Die sind langsam, da sind sie.
Und jetzt sind sie doch sehr stark.
Ja, Sie meinen im Laufe der Zeit sind die Schmerzen scherengehalten?
Ja, in den letzten Tagen haben die mehr zugenommen.
Und sind die Schmerzen irgendwelche Region ausstrahlen?
Also ich habe den Eindruck manchmal tut es auch in der rechten Leiste so ein bisschen weh.
Rechtenleisten.
Ja, Sie meinen rechten unten, ja?
Rechtenleiste.
Untenbau.
Dort wo eben das Früftgelenke, so in dem Bereich, die Leiste, da tut es weh.
Und sind die Schmerzen irgendwelche Region gewandert?
Nein, nur, dass ich Ihnen gesagt habe, die sind da so im Unterbauch.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, dass der Schmerz so ein bisschen die Leiste da hochzieht.
Ja, okay.
Herr Müller, verstehe ich.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auch eine Schmerzfälle von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 sehr leite Schmerz und 10 unerträglich Schmerzen ist.
Dann würde ich ja sagen so 5.
Und wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie dumpf, drückend oder stehend?
Also das sind keine drückenden Schmerzen, aber es sind so dauerhafte,
so wie die Schmerzen, die weniger brennen.
Ja.
Und sind die Schmerzen immer da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Also manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, es wird ein bisschen weniger,
aber die sind fast immer gleich.
Und gibt es bestimmte Auslöse, dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ich meine nach dem Essen oder nach dem Fettiges Essen oder beim Stehen oder Liegen oder Hochlagen.
Mit dem Essen hat es nichts zu tun.
Ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, wenn ich Stuhlgang habe,
wird es dann etwas weniger oder wenn ich Wasser lassen muss, dann wird es auch etwas weniger.
Ja, Sie meinen beim Wasser lassen wir Stuhlgang, die Schmerzen lindert?
Ja, danach werden wir wenigstens weniger.
Und wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang?
Also der ist normal, wieder fest, noch dünnflüssig.
Also der ist normal, aber wie gesagt, auch immer die Schmerzen werden etwas weniger,
wenn ich auf Toilette gewesen bin.
Und wann war Ihre letzte Stuhlgang?
Das war gestern Abend.
Haben Sie schon mal diese ähnliche Beschwerden erledigt?
Nein, das habe ich bisher noch nie gehabt.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Fieber. Haben Sie das gemessen?
Ja, das war 39 Grad gewesen.
Und wie haben Sie das gemessen?
Im Ohr?
Ja, ich habe da so ein neues digitales Gerät und das muss ich nur in die Ohr hineinhalten,
dann zeigt er mir an, wie hoch das ist.
Und das hat 39 Grad angegeben.
Und wann haben Sie das gemessen?
Gestern Abend.
Und haben Sie Schuttelefrost oder Nachschweiß?
Also in den letzten zwei Tagen habe ich den Eindruck, dass ich ein bisschen verschwitzt bin in der Nacht.
Aber sonst habe ich keinen Schuttelefrost oder Nachschweiß.
Und gestern mit dem Fieber, da habe ich ein bisschen gezittert nach dem Fieber.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Nein, damit habe ich keine Probleme.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungefähr sechs Monate ungewölt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Damit habe ich keine Probleme.
Ja, das ist schon.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also mein Appetit ist ganz normal.
Ich kann ganz normal essen und trinken.
Da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Ja, das ist schon.
Und haben Sie irgendeine frische chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine ja Blutzucker, Blutotruck.
Nein, bisher nichts bekannt.
Ich habe ein Ja-Bete-Fürst-Kein-Blutzucker.
Und auch der Blutdruck war normal.
Ich war vor vier Wochen beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Der hat alles kontrolliert und sagt, das ist alles okay.
Ja, sehr schön, sehr schön, Hermela.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, eine Operation habe ich nicht gehabt.
Und nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein, keine.
Und reagieren Sie allergisch irgendwelche Medikamente oder Lebensmittel?
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Ich bin nicht bekannt, nein.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Coronavirus?
Ja, mittlerweile schon die vierte Impfung gehabt.
Ja, vierte Impfung, ja schon.
Und waren Sie schon einmal im Ausland?
Ja, in letzter Zeit nicht vor zwei Jahren vor der Pandemie.
Da war ich mal im Ausland.
Und rauchen Sie, Hermela?
Nein, ich auch nicht.
Ja, schön.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten.
Was trinken Sie?
Wenn wir mal Weihnachten oder zu Geburtstagen vielleicht ein Gläschen Wein, aber mehr nicht.
Und das ist eine Routinefrage, bitte.
Und ich muss das fragen, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen, nein, damit habe ich nichts zu tun.
Und haben Sie regelmäßig Ihre Hausarzt besucht?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich war zu ländlich vor vier Wochen beim Ausland gewesen.
Und haben Sie Ihre alte Versorgung durchgeführt?
In meinen Vorsorgeuntersuchungen?
Ja, ja, Vorsorgeuntersuchungen.
Ja, ja, also auch eine Post-Auto-Untersuchung.
Und vor einem Jahr hatte ich auch eine Marke und Darmspiegelung gehabt.
Ja, das war schon.
Und haben Sie kein Problem?
Nein, kein Problem.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die sind noch bei dem Leben.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Ja, so was man im Alter hat.
Mein Vater hat eine Altersdiabetes.
Und die Mama hat ein bisschen mit dem Blutdruck zu kämpfen.
Ja, und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen jüngeren Bruder und eine ältere Schwester.
Ja, und sind Sie auch gesund?
Die sind beide gesund, ja.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Und, ja, sind Sie Rentner?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Elektroingenieur.
Elektroingenieur.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Seit ungefähr 20 Jahren.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe auch zwei Jungs und einen Mädchen.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Ja, den fehlt nichts, Gott sei Dank.
Ja, okay.
Und treiben Sie Sport, Herr Müller?
Ich mache eigentlich regelmäßig Sport.
Ich jogge zweimal die Woche.
Ja, das wäre schon sehr wichtig für Ihre Alten.
Und für Gesundheit.
Und Herr Müller, ich denke, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzuzogen?
Oder haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, nicht.
Ja.
Und jetzt, ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersochen.
Danach bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ich würde gerne auch Ultraschall, Bauchultraschall veranlasen.
Danach, ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Wie wir weiter vorgehen, dann komme ich wieder auf.
Okay.
Ja, alles klar.
Okay, bis gleich.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie dort einen Zauber aufgestoßen?
Nein, dort haben wir nicht.
Wir haben gesagt, gestern ist der Zugang gehn.
Gehn winden ab momentan.
Nein, Winde, damit habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Übelkeit, Erbärmung?
Nein, das habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Als erstes, ich habe eine Anfänge.
Können wir anfangen, ja.
Ja, okay.
Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Frage.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Aber Sie haben nicht.
Ich habe nicht eingenommen.
Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich berichte über ihn.
Sagen Sie doch einfach, ich würde Ihnen gerne
einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, ich würde gerne einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, machen Sie den.
Okay, Manfred Müller ist 55 Jahre Patientin.
Er stelle sich seit vier bis fünf Tagen aufgetreten.
스타uige, AA auftreten da auf трудig ente.
Im laufe der Zeit verstütkt.
Ja, Branen der soy der.
Ja mittel mitelbauch beer
Er berichtete im Laufe der Zeit, die Schmerzen wurden im Laufe der Zeit in rechten untenbereich ausstrahlen
und Schmerzintensität liegen fünf auf einer Schmerzkala von 11.
Er teilte mit, die Schmerzen nach dem Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen vermindert.
Er bemerkte, seit zwei Tagen fühle er sich auf den Stuhlgang und er hat sich auf den Stuhlgang vermindert.
Er war nicht erfühlig, sondern er hat gestern aufgefiebert mit Temperaturen bis 39 Grad.
Er habe Fieber im Ohr und gestern Abend gemessen.
Er hatte diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal.
Er hatte die Fragen nach Sodbrennen, Neusa, Emesis, wurden verneint.
Er hatte die Vegetatik, die Anamnese, bis auf Fieber nach Schweiß und siehte unaufheilig.
Er hat die Frage, ob er in den letzten Tagen oder schon längere Zeit vermindert ist.
Er hat die Frage, ob er in der Nacht wiederholt.